It's going to be a big year for spooky new
supernatural series, whether we're talking
about haunted houses or magical adventures.
From high fantasy to horror and everything
in between, these are the TV shows we're looking
forward to in 2020.
Netflix has so much content that you'll basically
never run out of shows to power through, especially
when it comes to genre shows.
The real problem is finding the good ones.
Here's a hot tip for this year's marathon
viewing: if you're a fan of supernatural drama,
then absolutely check out Spectros.
It's a new Brazilian series from writer/producer
Douglas Petrie, and if his name sounds familiar,
you might just recognize it from two truly
iconic spooky shows, Buffy the Vampire Slayer
and American Horror Story: Coven, on which
he served as a writer and producer.
The eight-episode first season is set to introduce
viewers to the Liberdade district of Sao Paulo,
Brazil, the home to a large and vibrant Japanese
population.
Because of this blending of cultures, the
story which follows five teenagers as they
encounter the supernatural will be an intriguing
mix of Brazilian folklore and Japanese ghost
stories.
Season 1 of Spectros is set to debut on Netflix
on February 20.
Dispatches From Elsewhere, the new AMC series
created by Jason Segel, looks like it has
the potential to break out of the narrow confines
of genre into something truly unexpected.
Trailers for the series frame it as an interesting
hybrid of conspiracy thriller, psychedelic
adventure, and uplifting journey of self-discovery.
There are plenty of questions begging for
answers as the characters search for a mysterious
woman named Clara and argue over whether or
not what they're doing is a real quest or
just an elaborate hoax.
With that in mind, we really don't know how
much fantasy will actually be involved in
this series, but we can't wait to find out.
With an ensemble cast that includes Academy
Award winner Sally Field, André 3000 of Outkast
fame, and others, Dispatches from Elsewhere
arrives March 1.
Unless you've been hiding out in a bunker
for the past decade or just woke up from a
coma, you probably know a thing or two about
The Walking Dead.
It began as a comic book series and then expanded
to television in 2010, where it quickly became
one of the biggest things in the history of
cable TV.
Since then, the flagship series in the franchise
has continued its run on AMC, and a spinoff
series titled Fear the Walking Dead has enjoyed
its own successful run.
Now, in 2020, it's time for yet another expansion.
In addition to a promised series of films
starring original Walking Dead hero Rick Grimes,
the Walking Dead universe is adding a third
series to its ranks with The Walking Dead:
World Beyond.
This new series will take us into the story
of the first generation of young people who've
actually grown up with the apocalypse.
They've come of age in a world of privilege,
behind walls that protected them from the
walkers beyond.
Now it's time for them to venture out into
the hellish landscape for the first time,
and we can't wait to see what that looks like.
World Beyond premieres April 12.
Though it reached a climax of sorts with Avengers:
Endgame in 2019, the Marvel Cinematic Universe
isn't slowing down any time soon.
We'll be seeing new characters and old favorites
from Marvel for years to come, and a lot of
that is going to be happening on the small
screen.
That includes plenty of new shows including
The Falcon and the Winter Soldier and WandaVision
arriving on Disney+ in the coming months,
but even that's not all.
We'll also be seeing new interpretations of Marvel heroes over on Hulu, including Helstrom.
Helstrom is based on the Marvel Comics characters Daimon and Satana Helstrom, who in their original forms
are presented as the literal children of Satan. In the new Hulu series, Daimon and Ana are cast as the children of a
horrific serial killer, who attempt to make amends for their father's wrongs by hunting down the worst that humanity has to offer.
Much like Doctor Strange before it, we can
expect Helstrom to dig into some of the more
occult-heavy corners of the Marvel Universe,
and we'll find out exactly how it does that
when the series lands on Hulu at some point
in 2020.
Penny Dreadful launched in 2014 as a new take
on the pulpy, sensationalized fiction from
which it derived its title.
Over the course of three seasons, viewers
met familiar faces ranging from the vampire-hunting
Abraham Van Helsing to Victor Frankenstein
and his infamous monster or monsters, as the
case may be and saw them re-interpreted in
exciting new ways that made for an addictive
horror series.
Now, in 2020, the next chapter in the Penny
Dreadful story begins.
While the original series took place in the
1800s and had a very European feel, Penny
Dreadful: City of Angels will move its location
to exactly where the title suggests.
The new series is set in Los Angeles during
the Golden Age of Hollywood, and because of
its California roots it will also pull heavily
from Mexican folklore for its subject matter.
Viewers can look forward to plenty of horrific
new delights, including demons walking the
Earth and the Mexican deity Santa Muerte.
Starring Natalie Dormer of Game of Thrones
and The Hunger Games fame, Daniel Zovatto,
Nathan Lane, and more, Penny Dreadful: City
of Angels arrives on April 26.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.